insta breasts they're coming people what
are they take a look we've been looking
for a bigger bust can now go up a full
cup size the effect is pretty much
instantaneous just one catch it lasts
just 24 hours katie has a big date
tonight her one-year anniversary with
her boyfriend
I really have surprise for Shay New York
cosmetic surgeon dr. Norman Rowe says
women like Katy come in when they have a
special event where they want to look
great but most other patients come in
when they just want to try out what
they'll look like with permanent
implants it didn't take long an
injection of a bag of saline and less
than half an hour
voila I love that I will have a surprise
for him which basically means like if I
sleep with him and we wake up the next
morning my kids are gonna be a lot
smaller than they were last night all
right so there's another surgeon now
working on something that's gonna last
two or three weeks so this would be like
vacation breasts not just the one knife
breast it's the breast do you want the
instant rest is just so ridiculous if
anyone's gonna jab a needle into my
chest it's to awaken me from my heroin
overdose I mean the whole idea is just
crazy because it's not just they put a
needle here I can't assume it is they
put a needle here and it fills up the
whole breast I mean say got to put
needles all over your boobs you know it
just seems like there's a ridiculous
idea on the planet okay so we know that
look we're in Los Angeles here I walk
around all the time in constant
amazement of the ridiculous plastic
surgery that people have women of course
but now I'm seeing a ton of it with men
temporary maybe it's a little better
like you need like a little boost on a
given evening maybe there's something
I'm trying to give these guys the
benefit of it out here the bathroom you
go from a c-cup yeah
you know I think this is so interesting
and I mean it's I grew up in Seattle
hippie parents like that whole world and
completely you know thought never never
would I ever get a spray tan that's
happened
never would I ever get plastic surgery
that haven't happened but like I
guarantee every sort of small boobed
woman out there has at one point maybe
googled like natural breast enhancement
or like augmentation whatever that is
and most of them end up getting scared
away from it are not really willing to
accept the risk with it so like assuming
which is probably not a great assumption
that this is totally safe this temporary
thing I think that it's actually a
really interesting sort of like training
wheels for plastic surgery and I think
that most small boob girls if they were
to get it to say oh do I maybe want
permanent breast enhancement would
experience it for a couple weeks and be
like that was fun and then go back
because honestly like when you don't
have we're up for all the time it's
worried about the effects of gravity as
much like it's a better I think it's a
better life so I think there's gonna be
like a grass is greener moment that
happens a lot ease will end up not going
through with it yeah I did not think of
ahead I actually think that's kind of
interesting like a little test run and
then you can decide if you want to go
forward or perhaps you decide you don't
what we just have been saying image
problems right cuz even the idea the
idea of the two three-week thing the the
24 hour one it's for a date as that girl
is gone on and but even that you're
selling false goods like isn't that a
problem like of course we all sell false
goods all the time you go on a date
women puts on all kinds of makeup the
guy might shave or you know like we all
we all do that but isn't is there some
risk in that that we're all selling
something that is not real
absolutely and that it's geared
specifically towards women although they
do say that they will they can inject it
into a man's calves to make their calves
which is code for penis I think our
young people and and a man would never
put that in his penis cuz women would be
like you taste salty enough anyway cuz
it's made from saline they won't even
say what's in the two or three week
product and it's like look this is going
into women's bodies it's not the secret
recipe
for coca-cola you know anything like
that's pretty that's pretty crazy allow
me to quote Beyonce here because my
producer did a fine job and gave me a
Beyonce quote is it our souls that need
surgery not our bodies
apparently Beyonce said that you know
about this Beyonce and jay-z you know
about Beyonce oh yeah yeah but is it is
it our souls like are we brought in on
the inside while we do all this stuff on
the outside and now we're doing it
temporarily to fake it you go on
vacation and you feel better on the
beach and then you come home back to
your regular life and your regular boobs
and you're screwed someone could
surgically improve my soul that'd be
amazing wouldn't it that would be
absolutely amazing deep on the show here
I yeah I mean I think it's you know
looking at if everyone's end goal is
happiness what are the means to that end
and some people make the assumption that
it is money or that it is changing your
physical appearance and I you know I
think there's definitely something to be
said for wondering what it would be like
to be in another person's body for a
minute or for a lifetime or whatever
that is and chances that you have to
temporarily experience that whether it's
by augmenting your physical appearance
or just putting yourself in some of the
shoes going in volunteering going and
experiencing life in a different country
anything that sort of changes your
perspective temporarily on your own
situation and puts into perspective your
problems and it's gonna be it's gonna be
great and that's all you know maybe go
volunteer instead of getting a boob job
but like having an amazing like a
creative imagination you know by wanting
to experience how other people live
their lives by basically putting a
fix-a-flat can up to your breasts
I don't know how oh yeah all right well
I'm with Molly the the meaning of life
is trying to get some happiness I hope
you've gotten a little happiness while
watching this and maybe if you get the
breasts let us know you can comment
right down below
[Music]